president biden challenged states to  ensure all americans  be eligible for covet 19 vaccines no  later than may 1st  mr president challenge accepted  beginning on april 5th all nevadans 16  and older will be eligible  to schedule vaccination appointments  statewide  april 5th all nevadans will be eligible  to schedule vaccination appointments i  want to be clear  opening up the state to eligibility on  april 5th  does not mean that every nevadan will be  able to make an appointment  and get a vaccine on april 5th  availability of vaccines  and appointments will still be dependent  on the allocation of doses we receive  from the federal government  however this will allow more nevadans to  schedule appointments  and receive their shot in an easier way  by opening up eligibility to all  nevadans 16 and older on april 5th  means that families friends and  coworkers can seek this opportunity  together  which will help address accents access  and hesitancy